- Hey guys, how's it going?
So I was just sitting
playing Zelda and I thought
'hey, I still have all my
recording stuff set up,
so why not record some
game play for you guys?'
You seemed to enjoy it the last time,
and in response to a
bunch of your comments,
I was talking about how I didn't pre-order
anything but the Switch.
No accessories, no anything,
and the case I showed
in my last video was so awful.
I packaged it back up
and I'm returning it.
Unfortunately, I kind of destroyed the box
so I hope that they accept it as a return.
I hated everything about that case.
One of my favorite
comments was everybody was
comparing it to an old school CD case,
which you're right, it did look like that.
Today we're gonna take a
peek at the pro controller.
(box and plastic ripping)
Very nice!
It comes with a charger
cable, USBC, thank you!
Wow, this is a really nice feel.
Too bad I've basically
beat the entire game
using that little tiny controller dock,
which surprisingly isn't that bad.
I actually kind of like it.
I mean, this is such a better feel though.
There's a lot of weight to it as well.
This doesn't feel bad to me.
What's interesting is depending
upon how you hold this,
those joysticks are about
the same width apart.
They're a little bit further
apart on this guy though.
But not by much!
Now I wanna show you guys some
of the cases that I decided to go with.
This one, it's perfect!
It is a nice (knocks) hard shell.
It's got a nice little place
here to put your Switch
when you have the joy cons attached.
It's got a place for your games,
and it's got some little areas up here to
put your chords and whatever else
you might wanna be putting in there.
In case you're short on room,
this is an even harder
shell cover. (knocks)
It's got a place here for the tablet,
a place for games, and
I like this has a little
zipper pocket up here.
You could put your joy cons, your cables,
and, um, candy?
(zipper zips)
Got a little hanging wrist
strap which is very nice.
Those zippers are really loud!
This one has a nice
little carrying handle,
and it also comes with this little clip.
These are so much better,
there's actually no comparison at all.
This is another case, but this
is actually for my Mavic Pro.
This'll be in a separate video,
I'm going to be doing one about
how I transport my drones,
and what cases I use
and this juts came in.
So here's a sneak peak!
It's got a place for the drone and
also a place for the controller.
(zips zipper)
Future video right here!
So those are the cases that I'm probably
going to be using.
I feel like this is going
to be the one that I
use most of the time.
It fits in my backpack, and it
fits pretty nicely everywhere
and I can also just take it to go,
and use it as a little purse.
There's no logos,
there's no nothing on it.
I like that!
This one has a tiny little logo,
but I can't really tell what it even is,
so it doesn't really matter.
I like no logos, I like
just plain, basic, simple.
Now I've taken a peek at those cases,
should we play some Zelda then?
I'm not really sure where I'm gonna go,
I just officially unlocked the entire map.
There's a few places that
I haven't really explored
very much, but, I don't know!
Let's see.
If you don't want any spoilers whatsoever,
you can stop watching
now, but I'm not gonna
give any storyline spoilers,
but I might be showing you some things
that you haven't actually
got to in the game.
So there's your heads up!
Let's play!
Let me get my blanket
so I'm nice and comfy.
We're gonna play this game!
Where am I?
I just got to this area,
I just unlocked the Lakeside Stable.
Let's see, I just picked up
a scale from this dragon.
I'm not sure where I gotta go,
cause I know there's probably
a secret shrine there.
Farosh's Scale.
This precious scale that
contains powerful electricity...
Most of the scales that you'll find,
you need to throw them
into a little spring.
Oh, what's that?
I hear, there's a shrine nearby!
(soft music)
Where is it?
It's probably up there somewhere.
Look at these bananas!
Yes!
I'm assuming it's up here.
God, I have no patience for
climbing up mountains, at all.
I just wanna keep hitting 'x' and jump
all the way up there to my victory.
So here's the unfortunate
reality the fact that I
just jumped up here, it doesn't seem
like that shrine is up here.
He made me really upset!
Okay, that was an accident. (laughs)
It seems like it's inside here!
Well how do I get in there?!
(soft music from game)
(gasps)
Right here!
How did I miss it?!
I missed it!
God, this is why I have 100
freakin' hours of this game!
(explosion on game)
(grunts)
When something seems like it should be
the way that it is usually is.
If somebody, you think, is being an idiot
and they're screwing
you over or something,
they probably are! (blows raspberry)
Many times I've been
screwed over to learn that.
Let's go, let's see what
this shrine has to offer.
(grunts)
Oh no!
Halt the Tilt, well this should be fun.
Oh geeze, it literally
tells you what to do,
but yet I still ran up it knowing exactly
what was gonna happen.
(game chimes)
Oh geez!
Oh god!
Oh boy!
Oh man!
We're gonna go over here first.
Let's get, let's see what's in here.
A nice little present perhaps?
(game chimes)
My inventory is full.
Hmm, guess it doesn't matter then!
(game rings)
(game chimes)
Alright, so there's our
little end goal there.
Is there something up there?
(game chimes)
No!
Okay, well we made it!
Oh, but I wanna go up there!
Can I just....
Use my Magnesis?
Okay, looks like we can't do that.
Well it's probably something dumb,
and I don't care.
And if it is something awesome,
I'm gonna be super upset about it later,
but I can always come back.
(game chimes)
Cool story, let's roll.
So really great story,
when I was talking to
you guys the last time
about my inventory and
I couldn't find the guy
to upgrade my inventory slots,
I never upgraded the
first time that I met him,
so I was going to all of
these freaking stables
going absolutely nuts, trying to find him.
I was already in the forest
where he would have been
if I had met him at the stables,
and I go back to his original location,
and he is just there shaking his maracas,
saying 'baby, you wanna upgrade?'
And I felt like such an absolute idiot.
I was like, I can't
believe he's still here.
He's still here!
Okay so I need to find a spring somewhere.
I gotta go up here because
I already got my dragon
and then it's this way.
Let's travel up here and
then we'll just hop down
and see what we can see what we can see.
So whenever you get the
scales from the dragons,
you have to defeat the one
dragon and then the other two
I'm not sure if you have
to defeat them later,
but you shoot them and you get a scale,
and then you take the scale
and you drop it into a spring,
and then you open up a secret shrine!
I love this game so much.
I like hate everything
about what I've become.
I can't wait to beat it.
Oh, look at you guys, just
fighting down there like pigs.
I'm gonna have a lot of
things to do to get to there.
Hopefully this is even the
spring that I need to get to,
or I'm gonna be so upset.
What's great is if you're
just staring this game,
you're gonna have absolutely
no idea what I'm talking about.
It's not even really gonna matter.
But then when you do get to these parts,
you're gonna be like 'oh,
that's right! That's right.'
This is actually pretty easy.
(game whooshes)
(game chimes)
I hate those stupid things,
I forget what they're called,
but they're dumb!
I think what I might do,
let me make sure I have my armor on.
Oh shoot, I wanted to drive, but whatever.
It's not even a big deal.
(game splashes)
Let's swim up here.
(game chimes)
(groans)
Get off of me!
You stupid!
Idiot!
And you know what else?!
You're also an idiot!
Come on, oh shoot, I missed him.
I missed him!
You're dumb.
I hate your stupid skeleton head.
I hate your stupid freaking face.
I'm gonna stasis your dumb mouth.
I need to be using regular arrows
cause I'm really wasting those.
(game chimes)
Gonna give you just one extra shot,
just because you're a idiot.
(game chimes)
Okay, this is, this is what we came for.
It's like I feel almost
like it's cheating,
but okay leave me alone.
Oh, no no no, come back!
Hey show yourself to me baby!
(game chimes)
Come here!
Pig!
I need to figure out about these things
because it looks like
there's something cool there,
but I haven't figured it out yet.
Is that the dragon?
Is he here?!
He's here!
There he is!
Oh, he's so...
I absolutely love the music
when the dragon is around.
Oh god, that's scary.
So it looks like there's a shrine
somewhere super super close.
It's gotta be behind this waterfall!
So this doesn't look to
be what I was hoping for.
Because usually there's a statue
and maybe it's over here?
Oh man!
Did I go all this way for nothing?
Hey!
Stop shooting me!
(game chimes)
(scoffs)
God I hate these stupid idiots.
Stop it!
(game chimes)
Okay well this is not good.
Oh, you're looking for your head?!
Oh you're gonna take that one?!
Good for you, well guess what?!
I'm destroying this head
so no one can have it!
Then no one can have it!
And I want your stupid arm!
(game chimes)
I'm in struggle city right now!
Here he is!
Where are you going?
So, where are you going buddy?
He's going in there!
Oh man!
That's where his home is.
Okay.
Oh no my, oh here, I'll get another scale.
Shoot!
If you see, he dropped
the scale over here.
So hey, that's cool!
I'll have two.
Get up, pick it up!
Great. That's exciting!
I had to look it up because I don't know.
This is so far away!
It looks like it is somewhere over here.
I bet it's over here.
I bet it's here, this has got to be it!
Let's add that there and
see if we can get there.
(game chimes)
Unfortunately, there's no
easy way for me to get there
because I don't have any
shrines in the area.
So I'm thinking this is
probably my best bet,
to go here and then cruise
up the river somehow.
This wasn't even what I planned
on doing for this video.
But here we are!
Oh look, it's a shrine up there too.
It's gonna take me forever to get there!
I get so nervous when it's raining because
I think I'm just gonna slip and fall.
I'm not even bothering with you and
your stupid chuchu jelly.
(game character grunts)
Well if all else fails, I
can just go get that shrine.
(game chimes)
I hate these stupid chuchu jelly hogs!
(gasps loudly)
So I've never beat one of these yet!
Should I attempt it?
I'm terrified.
Oh my goodness!
Okay this is gonna be a first for me.
(dramatic game music)
(game chimes)
Am I doing damage?
Whoo!
(cheers)
That's my first time!
I've just been running and avoiding them
this whole entire time!
(game chimes)
He was easy.
The other ones with the legs are
a little bit more difficult.
(game chimes)
Okay, we're not actually that far away.
That didn't take very long.
I thought it was gonna take a lot longer.
It was so hard on that little
tiny map I was looking at.
It was barely even visible.
Is this it?
This doesn't seem to be where I wanna be.
This doesn't look like a spring at all.
(sighs)
Shoot.
(game character grunts)
Man...
Oh yes!
Here it is!
We're in the right place baby!
Let me pray to you my sweet sweet statue!
I've got it, I've got it, I've got it!
I've got the scale, I've got
the scale, I've got the scale!
You ready for me?
I'm gonna drop it like it's
hot, drop it like it's hot.
(game chimes)
Lead my way.
I think there's one more dragon.
(dramatic music)
But I'm not sure.
Cause I've done three.
Yes, I'll take it!
How many...
I've got four.
I've been debating whether I
up my stamina one more time,
or if I just go do hearts,
because I've been pretty
good with the stamina
that I currently have right now.
I don't even have to do anything!
You're rewarding me for
being incredibly gifted!
Normally what happens, the
past ones that I've done,
I've found the shrines
first and then I've had to
find the dragon so this
time it was a little bit
backwards so I had absolutely
no idea where this was.
I'll drop that.
Those are easy, easy to get.
(game chimes)
Cool.
Give me my orb!
(dramatic game music)
Cool!
Alright what should we do?
What do we do?
I have yet to tackle Hyrule Castle.
I think my best bet though is
to go to that other shrine.
Oh, pardon me!
Let me...
(game character grunts)
Beat this guy first.
Oh, excuse me, hello?!
What is happening?!
My game is freezing.
I've never had this happen!
Oh god!
What'd I get, did I get a present?
Thank you!
What's in here?
Be something good.
(game chimes)
Oh, yes please!
If I do say so myself, I thank you!
What do we do now?
That's basically all I
ever say to myself is...
Oh shoot!
We're screwed!
We're in trouble now.
We're in trouble now!
The blood moon is just gonna rise,
and then it's gonna be
completely pointless anyway.
I'm out.
This is me just running from my problems.
And I am okay with that!
What I would like to do though is,
let's see, is that that shrine
that I was trying to get?
It looks like I could
probably get to it from here!
Let's go, let's go take a visit.
(gasps)
Oh yeah.
That's not what I was planning...
Let's just go to Hyrule,
let's see what we can see.
Let's do it, let's do it.
What else do I have to do today?
Nothing, I have nothing else to do today,
except edit this video.
I haven't even gotten anywhere near it.
I've been just staying away.
Let's just go take a peek!
Let's see, let's see what's up!
Oh, you know what?
These, I can take you on now
because I am all powerful.
This looks so scary.
I don't wanna beat the game because
I don't wanna be done with it.
Like it's basically all I have
to look forward to right now,
like 'hey, make it through
the day, you get to
go play Zelda.'
(game whistles)
Oh, there's a shrine nearby?
Oh god, oh boy!
(game chimes)
I've never even tried to beat these guys,
because I've never been strong enough!
Let's beef up!
What do I got?
What?!
Wait a minute, I thought
I was supposed to reflect!
Jesus! What is this?!
What do I think I am?!
Oh god, oh jeeze!
I bet I can't even get up!
This is a bad idea.
Why would I think 'you know
what, I'm just gonna hop
in here having not even tried to beat
one of these dudes yet' and just do it?
Great idea.
My shield broke.
God I'm a mess.
Like everyone's trying to get me.
This is such a stupid...
Like who do I think I am right now?
(game explosions)
This is so dumb, I'm screwed.
Like I absolutely am such an idiot!
(laughs)
Holy crap!
I've got so many of them on me!
(somber music)
I was not prepared, I was a little cocky,
I thought I could take
on one, not all of them.
I guess let's hit up one more
shrine and be done with it.
How 'bout it?
I bet those have to go in there.
(game sword clanks)
(game chimes)
Well that was a little bit too far!
Is that gonna be....
Well that didn't work out so well either.
Well, all right, that's
kind of close though.
I bet we can get them in there.
Nope, this way, oh god.
(game chimes)
Yes! Yes!
Oh no, no, no, no, no!
Okay we're almost there.
(game chimes)
If you don't go in there,
I'm gonna be so upset.
(game chimes)
Yes, give me your seed bro!
How am I gonna get up there quickly?
Oh, is there a shrine near by?
No, I wouldn't have thought.
(game chimes)
You think I'm climbing up this mountain
cause I feel like it?!
Do you think that's why
I'm just doing this for...
Actually I am doing it for fun.
We're actually almost there.
Uh oh, chilly!
(game chimes)
Okay, we made it!
Here we are, we're at the shrine.
Well this looks terrible.
The shrine atop these
peaks share a connection.
Their memory the answer
to the other's question.
Alright, well apparently I
have to go to the other shrine
and figure out what, uh,
that's gonna be too much
for the rest of this video.
So, with that being said,
feel free to leave me
any helpful tips or
anything else that you think
that I might be into
in the comments below.
No end spoilers, but I'm
totally fine with hints,
tips, cheats, tricks,
anything that you think
that I should find that I haven't already,
I mean, I'm doing a pretty good job.
I'm pretty happy so far with my progress.
We've got three divine beasts down,
I've got one more to go.
I'm just not ready to go there yet.
Well thank you guys so much for watching.
Hope you guys enjoy this.
If you did, let me know
if you wanna see more.
Also, let me know, and I'll see you guys
in whatever video I happen to post next!
So, that's it, bye!
I've got to cook that, okay ready?
(electric mixer mixing)
Oh god!
No no no no no!
Let's add the other half, I
don't know why we do that.
(video game explosion)
Really this is our last step!
No!